new rules are in the works to cut back
on the amount of sugar and salt that our
kids consume at school but that's long
been a mission for some CCSD students
and schools Joshua peguero visited
Northwest Career and Technical Academy
to share what they've been cooking up
students are dicing veggies and
coordinating with each other in this
kitchen inside Northwest CTA High School
John Paul Galvan developed the love of
cooking at home helping his mom in your
Junior and Senior year you gain college
credits for this as if you're going to
culinary school Northwest
ETA is one of ccsd's magnet schools
students have to apply to attend and
they are then selected through a lottery
system once enrolled students are
required to maintain High grades the
culinary program is sought after by
students and parents due to how well
kids are prepared for the work field
when you get into the job field you
already have some skills like food
safety along and then also kind of like
some skills on like knife cuts and
culinary arts most of the food cooked by
The Culinary students comes to this Cafe
right here as you can see their streets
they also sell hot food and cold food
and all the funds generated by this food
goes right back into the culinary
program our students get to instead of
going to the lunchroom come over here
and try our Cafe Chef Aaron Clive to
Phillips an instructor says he tries to
teach students not only technical skills
but for them to expand what they eat and
aim for healthier foods I want to add a
little bit of cucumber and green onions
so we get to then influence the mass of
our school which then gives that broader
crowd of people starting to eat a
healthier approach and these Perez a
sophomore aspires to become a chef on
the Las Vegas Strip her background
influences her cooking I am
African-American Japanese and Hispanic
and Puerto Rican so and I really like
um doing Fusion food and she hopes to
share that with the public Joshua
preguero eight news now